from Universal Pictures marketing
department comes one of the most
expensive far-reaching promotional
campaigns of all time and also a movie
minions you loved the first two
despicable Me's now in the tradition of
Joey The Cleveland Show and the battle
for Endor comes a spin-off that takes a
character who's fun at small doses and
makes you wish they stayed in the
background get ready for a minions
origin story that doesn't even tell you
what a minion is or where their language
comes from
or whether they're immortal or whether
they have genders or why some have one
eye or why they always wear goggles or
how they reproduce but who cares
you're either six years old or a parent
wishing you could check your phone in
the movie theater Steve Carell is back
at the very end for like 30 seconds to
remind you how much better this movie
would have been with little GRU and some
minion babies instead hang with this
bland replacement scarlet overkill who
has our three heroes steal the Queen's
crown which they do growing up but I
thought then she hates them I don't want
you to take this the wrong way but I hit
you in 90 minutes of lazy gags that
makes cars to look like the beginning of
up featuring all these 1960s references
that don't belong in a movie for little
kids or their 30-something parents but
they will repeat the word banana over
and over and over again so Lisa's got
that going for it
but nah try to undo the harmful messages
the movie will drill into your kids
impressionable head like be a mindless
follower don't question authority and
shooting at the cops is okay as long as
you're little and cute that was great
you know for kids characters they really
do kill a lot of people so after Pixar
showed us that children's movies can be
great and the lego movie proved that
even shameless marketing can be fine let
minions remind you that cynical studio
branding exercises make just as crappy
films as you'd expect starring Sandra
Bullock's Sponge Bob round pegs Stuart
Little Kevin Hart only two minutes of
GRU for some reason and those horrible
face book means your aunt keeps posting
they don't have anything to do with
minions at all
despicable greed if they hadn't gotten
stuck in that ice cave the minions
totally would have helped Hitler in the
Nazis to write be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers
nothing gets nuclear fallout out of the
vinyl wood nothing fluffy gym poles and
cubbies my fluffy cow drops honey your
property now belongs to negan the next
person whose phone rings has to eat it
hold on to your Dookie it's about to get
spooky